[Music]
this
is star talk i'm your host neil degrasse
tyson your personal
astrophysicist and this week is a cosmic
queries edition
the always popular cosmic queries
and the topic the always popular search
for life in the universe and i've got
with me is my co-host matt kirschen man
hey hey neil how you doing okay i spent
all day yesterday trying to memorize the
name of your podcast it's probably
science
right it is i
was here for another variant but thank
you
i stumbled in my efforts there i found a
podcast called
sometimes or mostly science it's a whole
other podcast oh we hate them no we've
got a running rivalry with them it's
going to be it's going to totally have
rivalries
i got to make sure i get your stuff
right it's going to come to violence at
some point
probably so i know a little bit about
the search for life
but not as much as our guest today
uh our guest today is sarah seeger sarah
welcome to star talk
thanks for having me today yeah so sarah
let me get your full
title up here so uh your professor of
aeronautics and astronautics
physics and planetary science at mit
is that no they left out a few
categories
no no no it's it's because exoplanets
and the search for life is an incredibly
interdisciplinary talk
topic and it draws upon all those
different fields
excellent but but but between you and me
can i call you're a planetary scientist
right that's right yes yes
i mean my home is really in astrophysics
so
okay you could call me an astrophysicist
or a planetarium okay so you're in the
club
in the club so uh i guess the search for
life in the universe
has to necessarily include the search
for exoplanets
right they go together but is that part
of our bias
not necessarily we do i mean we're we're
definitely
pterocentric we're we definitely are
narrow-minded
but at the same time yeah like
earth-centric you know and on earth we
believe that for the origin of life we
need a place for ingredients to
concentrate
and it's it's hard to imagine
ingredients just you know concentrating
in
in the vastness and that low density of
outer space
okay so this concentration thing i think
is under celebrated out there
i mean in the public that people we take
it for granted that we have
rocks and buildings and mountains and
people
and for in our
greater universe nothing is together
i mean mostly it's mostly empty and
where it's not mostly empty
it's highly rarified and so
planets are really special places is
that right is that yeah
very special because they do concentrate
complex molecules they concentrate
elements
nutrients and everything we need
am i right in thinking they are
substantially less special or at least
less rare than we thought they were even
5-10 years ago yes actually we are
slowly making ourselves
less and less precious less and less
special
no sarah it's okay to know that you're
not just supposed to tell
people that i i think that's nice about
science i
like the fact that scientists sort of
switch between going you're incredibly
special and you're not special
we do we love thinking back to the
copernican revolution where before
copernicus the model of the universe was
that our earth
literally was at the center of the
universe all the planets
and the sun and the stars apparently all
orbited earth
i think i've heard is it andrean
described this sequence
uh some combination of her and the in
the carl sagan
uh camp uh referred to it as the
sequence of great demotions
for whatever we imagined ourselves to be
plus there was some rebuttal to that um
i forgot the fellow's name but he
wrote i think convincingly that the idea
that the idea that we are in the center
is not necessarily an elevated place
if heavens are above us right so the
center could be the slag heap of where
everything collects
and your ultimate goal is to ascend from
that to greater places
so but in either case the the location
was unique
i think so so in his mind we're like the
plug hole of the universe
we're sort of the drain
so so sarah you was it
natural to transition from exoplanet
discovery to the search for life
it wasn't someone had to nudge you or
was it just obvious as the next thing to
do
you know every scientist is different
and i've sort of been the random walk
type of scientist
like work on a problem and see a more
interesting problem
and then move over slowly
i like the dog being distract distracted
by the squirrel you know
yeah you can't keep it
so but but when you started out um
in the in the late 90s um we
we didn't didn't know many exoplanets
and even those that we did
it was fun to think of aliens on them
but there was no research
program there yet so so
it seems to me you were there at the
birth of this if not having birthed it
yourself
yes and in fact but just to go back even
further before my time perhaps even
before yours but in the decades past
if you look back like even you know just
after
um the time of sputnik like in the early
1960s there's actually a report
from a think tank kind of company and it
actually
talks about planets and exoplanets and
the chance for other earths
and even in the decades after that you
know there were always studies
on how would we go about finding another
earth and so when
exoplanets was born in the mid 1990s and
yes i was there i was a graduate student
working on exoplanets at the time
you know they were hot jupiters they
were not suitable for life in any way
but slowly those two things came
together you know all the past decades
of thinking about earth's
then switching gears to the hot giant
planets and so the thought of finding
earth and life it was kind of always
there in the background
even though it might have been a bit of
a stretch and just to be clear the
the jupiters that you're referring to
being hot was it was
easier to find really massive planets
first compared to low mass planets so
you're going to find it jupiter first
and we and they're hot because because
why because they're very close to the
star
so close to the star that as heated by
the star they're just
hot okay so the jupiters but they didn't
look like our
jupiter so so there again we were not so
we we thought we were representative of
the universe and we're not i mean at
least our solar
system right right we always expected to
find a jupiter where our jupiter is
which is you know five times further
from our sun than earth is and instead
we found
jupiter mass objects within a few you
know few day period orbits of the star
so even our bias that which shows up
every day in race relations and
sexism it even shows up in astrophysics
it does
yeah and you know the funny thing is is
just to take that a level further when
we
people first found these hot jupiters so
close to the star
we just assumed that they had the same
albedo the same reflectance properties
as jupiter itself
jupiter is quite bright you know you see
it in the sky because it's got icy
clouds
and we couldn't see jupiter in reflected
light and with a little more thought we
realized wow these
hot jupiters they're incredibly dark
they're very absorbing they have no
reflective clouds most of them wow
yeah wow okay so they're not only
so the big jupiters that don't look
anything like jupiter
that's what you're saying like i mean
yes and no they don't appear like their
atmospheres aren't like jupiter but
they're kind of bulk composition they're
mostly made of hydrogen and helium that
part's the same
all right so if you come to this as an
astrophysicist planetary scientist
and now you want to think about life you
gotta start knocking on the doors of
biologists so when did all that happen
remarkably it really it started
happening for me when i had my first
staff position
i worked at a place called the carnegie
institute of science
and i was in washington dc and it's
quite interdisciplinary there already
and they were already part of
of working on the somewhat new field
back then of astrobiology
so i started we're interacting with
biologists there and the funny thing was
is
i got a postdoc there and i signed him
up to work with me
and it literally took us like nine
months before we could even understand
each other
because our language was so different
yeah
so you need the coffee lounges you know
between
uh at the intersections of departments
because otherwise we just live in our
stove pipes and discoveries
go un un uh unattended too
and later on i attended an astrobiology
conference
and i met a remarkable person there who
became one of my closest colleagues and
so then through him
him being a biologist i was able to
learn and
create more more collaborators and so i
mean you have a fascinating
story i only recently learned that
you've actually
collected that together in a kind of a
memoir
the smallest lights in the universe so
congratulations on that memoir nice
published by crown in 2020 and because
we're all distracted by big explosions
and big lights and big things but maybe
the smallest lights in the universe i
guess these are the exoplanets
or it could be metaphor for other things
in the book
that it's just call attention to other
previously underserved domains of the
cosmos
thanks yeah so so let's get straight
let's get straight to this uh what is
life
you know in exoplanets we have a good
excuse for completely avoiding that
question
and we do we do i'll run it by you i'll
run it by you because
we have telescopes and we can see
atmospheres of other planets
we're hoping with our next generation
telescopes to see atmospheres of small
rocky planets
and we're going to look for signs of
life by way of gases that might be
attributed to life that have accumulated
in the atmosphere so we prefer to think
about
what life does life metabolizes
and it may give off gases during that
chemical process of metabolism
so we conveniently sweep that under the
rug and we just talk about what life
does
are you stupid under the rug because you
can't do anything about that question
anyway
we can't do anything about it and it's
just a question that no one wants to
agree on what what the answer is
so you but you sweep it under the rug
and say let's do it life
let's observe what life does so you're
the
atmospheric gases equivalent to the
people who study
um animal poop for example
it's it's things that life does even if
you're not studying the life itself
that's right that's right not to
equilibrate
your study with the study of species and
actually neil that that's never been
done before so that is
brand new it's a brand new analogy
so you're saying atmospheres on planets
are kind of the uh
animal remains of the galaxy well the
gaseous effluences
yes actually that's it that's a great
way to look at it actually yep
so sarah but but clearly
there are gases out there um and i want
to get to the q a because matt has them
lined up and i don't want to
lose any time on that but clearly
there's there's some gases let's take
methane for example um that
we know is the byproduct of life
not all life of course but some
bacterial life on earth
we know that so now let's look to
another place
like saturn's moon titan oh my gosh
it's completely covered in methane
so it must be teeming with life so we
but it's not so hot where did how what
you yeah yeah that's the single most
biggest problem that we need to be able
to see other gases in the atmosphere
and put the gas in question in context
with what else is there
but even doing that will be it'll still
be hard it'll be very
like a forensic crime scene you know how
do we pick out what is really life what
is really not made by life
so the gases you list that are the
products of life
are
necessary but insufficient to
prove that there's life yes actually and
that is the sort of
let's call it the dirty secret of the
whole field is that we'll never be able
to prove it
so in forensic crime scene terms you
sort of got to distinguish between
blood that was caused by the crime and
blood that was just previously existing
sort of decorative blood in that room
precisely just blood that someone had
put there that would just naturally be
there on the walls
in the splatter pattern yeah the normal
blood that would that exists in the room
i'm sure see sarah is going to put that
analogy in her next research paper
right let's just add an equation and
that's all sciences right
and you know it's in an equation it's
legit yeah and so on our earth we have
methane produced by life by bacteria
you know by cows but we also have
methane coming out of
mid-ocean ridges so in a lot of cases it
is definitely ambiguous
and methane is natural gas that we have
in our stoves right and i'm pretty sure
what's coming out of your stove is not
cow farts
it comes from another location on earth
okay
so matt we have a couple of minutes left
in this segment let's see if we can
squeeze in a question
okay great well this one i i love the
questions that come from uh our younger
listeners
so this one comes from carrie jenkins an
eight-year-old fan
i know how long do you think it'll take
for us to find
other life in the universe well
yeah how close are we sarah how many how
many more years what do we got here
well we actually will have we like to
say we'll have the
i'm not purposely trying to evade all
your questions honestly but
i would like to say that we will have
the capability to find signs of life
very soon with the launch of the james
webb space telescope
but whether we find life that really
depends on what's out there
you know if every planet has life if
life is extremely common
life that makes gases so i if you want a
concrete answer i could say anywhere
between
two years and 30 years
let's say okay so this would be the life
the usable life expectancy
of the james webb space well i was
putting the james webb whose
nominal life expectancy is five years
maybe ten
i was thinking of future telescopes
beyond the james webb
okay and possibly uh missions to the icy
moons of
jupiter um where there might be life
beneath the surface or even life
in beneath the surface of mars right i
mean why not
you're not looking for that life but you
got other people top people doing that
as well right okay so uh so
we might find life or definitely know
there isn't life
as we know it in the lifetime of this
eight-year-old girl
well maybe this eight-year-old girl will
carry the torch
if all the searches we're doing now are
exhausted maybe she'll be the one to
think of the next
new idea oh maybe you all aren't clever
enough and we need her to come along and
solve all the problems
all right we got to take a quick break
when we come back more start talk cosmic
queries
with my friend and colleague sarah
siegel we'll be right back
we're back star talk cosmic queries
search for life
edition i got with me my co-host matt
gershon matt
where do we find your podcast oh just
all the podcast places just bang for
yourself oh
oh that's your all your net your nearby
stores have any of them yeah go
go to your local uh go to your local
podcast supplier and just ask for
probably science and they'll find it
somewhere in the back there
do you also do stand-up comedy i do what
what i used to when
when indoor things were existed right
now
i talk into zoom recordings and pretend
i'm doing stand-up
okay this is during the in the in the
covert lockdown
yeah that was my day job and hopefully
will be again
excellent excellent and we have as my
special guest sarah seeger
who's an astrophysicist planetary
scientist searching for the exoplanet
searching for life
and she's our resident expert to field
these questions that matt has solicited
from our fan base
and this is the patreon fan base so what
more do you have matt for us i think
also by the way uh we should mention
that
our guest today isn't the only one with
a new book out and you've got
a book based on cosmic queries that has
a chapter that talks about the search
for life
oh yes indeed so
thanks for mentioning that because i
almost forgot i probably wouldn't have
forgotten by the end
but there's a book called cosmic queries
because this
format was so successful we said we've
got to do more
than just put it out there as a podcast
so there's a book called cosmic queries
that takes all the biggest questions
including this one and much of sarah's
research
that informs this field is contained
in that chapter and so in a celebration
of
cosmic queries as a thing and the search
for life
as a as a sub thing of the bigger thing
we've got sarah sieger
so sarah thank you again for being on
star talk and for checking in for this
so matt what do you have for us well
i've got to do another
another uh cosmic query question from
another young patreon
uh listener this comes from violetta
and violeta's mum izzy the letter is a
12 and a half year old astro fizzy kid
here in
alabama yep 12 and a half yes when
you're young those halves are important
and and asked professor sega i want to
know
firstly what exactly are biosignature
gases
and secondly what biosignature gases
would earth give off that would be
detectable by extraterrestrial life
who might be looking for inhabited power
planets like ours
perfect question yeah or would you not
need to look for our biosignature gases
because our existence would be pretty
obvious because the
space junk yes well a biosignature gas
is a signature of life it's a gas
produced by life that can accumulate in
an atmosphere of a planet
to a level that we can detect with our
telescopes
and if there are you know if there's i
love to imagine you know there
there are intelligent aliens on a planet
orbiting a nearby star
and they have the kind of space
telescopes we're building or hoping to
build
they would look at our earth and they
would definitely see a very strong
biosignature gas
and that's oxygen and oxygen fills our
atmosphere to 20
by volume but without plants without
photosynthetic bacteria
we would have literally virtually no
oxygen
so if all the plant life went away you
know
walked off the earth today how long
would it take for our oxygen supply to
sort of drop to zero
and why would it drop at all why
wouldn't it just stay there well
we also have bacteria that make oxygen
so
i'm not sure you know what the division
between all of those so no no just take
away everything that's making
everything take everything away so now
we've got 20
oxygen what happens to it well what
happens to it is oxygen is a highly
reactive gas
and it will just react away with other
molecules in the atmosphere with lots of
things on the surface
you know with gases coming out of vents
and volcanoes
and that oxygen just won't be there so
how about
over how much time would that take i
don't have that number off the top of my
head would it happen like next week or
in a year no no it wouldn't happen next
week it probably wouldn't happen in a
year
it's probably more like thousands of
years or even
okay or more okay so yeah so we if we
kill all the life
the the oxygenation life we can still
live out our lives with oxygen
subsequent generation will suffocate yes
probably we can live without our lives
okay so what you're saying is even
though this 20
has been stable over the his mostly
stable
it's not actually a stagnant number
because we are constantly producing it
and constantly removing it and it just
happens to be balanced at this number
right a fair way to say it that's a fair
way to say it right
all right all right matt all right
another one this this comes from
uh grumpster tough uh all one word i
hope i'm pronouncing that even closer
correctly
what is your most whatever you did it's
better than what chuck does with names
um what is your most optimistic
explanation
of the fermi paradox
i think we all have our favorite answer
to that one first what is the
fermi paradox the fermi paradox is the
idea that if
if there is intelligent life that
can harness energy and get in spacecraft
and
journey beyond their planet that they
should have colonized
the entire galaxy by now because once
they can get to one planet and colonize
that they can just
keep going and so the fermi paradox is
summed up by the question
where are they
so what you're saying is in the lifetime
of the galaxy
it doesn't really take that much time if
you're intelligent
by our measures to build spacecraft and
start traveling to planets
even if you can't travel at the speed of
light
right right that over time you would
eventually
reach planets and and colonize okay so
all right so where are they
well i i might okay so there's the
explanation i think is the real one and
then there's the one that i hope is the
real one
i like the experiment right so matt matt
the right they're already here
so you know one answer is that it just
takes too much energy like we
as humans we know now what it takes to
get in a spacecraft and go somewhere
that's a lot of resources so perhaps
they're just not
not doing that there's another answer
that
the intelligent civilization will
unfortunately and inevitably
self-destruct
they'll destroy their planet they'll
kill each other they'll they won't ever
reach
that kind of wouldn't that be the
definition of not being intelligent
yeah well it would be
my explanation that i love is i'll put
it to you this way just
imagine an ant an ant colony in your
house
you know what you might have or your
apartment and the ants they appear
kind of you know dumb but they're
somewhat clever right because they have
a society and
you see them doing like a reconnaissance
and i don't know if you've ever had this
but
you'll see like a few of them kind of
looking around and they might come
across like a piece of cat food on your
counter or something and then shortly
thereafter you have a huge stream of
them and they're all coming
to get this cat food in like a little
river well
you can mess them up if you like wipe
away their trail for a moment they kind
of get lost but i want you to imagine
you know neil
matt having a conversation with those
ants
like tell them about the universe tell
them about the hubble space telescope
and
the vastness of of the number of stars
in galaxies
like how on earth tell them about
calculus yes
yes so what i love to imagine is that
these to these intelligent aliens out
there
that we are like the ends like
why and how would they they contact us
okay so matt sarah is bumming us out now
first we're insignificant now we're just
plain stupid
well also i think it is worth pointing
out there are there are different
i mean like sarah was alluded to there
are very different types of intelligence
so you know i've been to university
you've both spent a lot more time in
academia
that we've all met people who are
incredibly smart in specific ways and
otherwise idiots
so you know maybe they have the ability
to travel across galaxies but they're
not the ability to not shoot themselves
within a very short amount of time
and maybe the official answer is they
think we're idiots
either they think we're idiots or we
think they are for having
self-destructed before they could get
here
oh there it is touche all right so matt
give me some more
so along the lines of uh interacting
with other
civilizations eric gross asks let's say
we discover proof of life not in our own
solar system but on some distant
celestial body
would there be any meaningful scientific
value of the discovery
or opportunity to expand upon the
knowledge it may of course have broad
societal and emotional
effects but would science practitioners
have any real hope of gaining more
information about life forms
that are at a minimum of 4.3 light years
from earth yeah so sarah i love that
question because
generally when we think of scientific
discoveries or advances we think okay
in five years or ten years engineers
will get a hold of it and they'll make
some
new device and we'll all be living
better and differently and so
life somewhere else that you can't
actually have a conversation with
even if it's intelligent and are you
getting secrets from that i mean what
if you can't or can you are we missing
something here
it's such a great question i mean we are
so wrapped up in the emotion and the
excitement
of the journey of exploration and of
being the first who can try to find out
what's what's out there
so in a practical sense not really i
mean we're not
we're not doing this to find anything
practical that said wouldn't it be
amazing if there is life
intelligent life on the nearest star
system for light years away we could
have a
very slow conversation but we could
imagine
no witty repartee there right send them
a message and you know four years later
you'll get their message back and we
could exchange
ideas about technology so if we wanted
to be practical like that's probably the
most practical avenue
so um but in terms of biology
unless we learn from them through these
radio signals what their
sort of biochemistry is like we wouldn't
get to compare dna or if they have dna
at all you wouldn't be able to do any
sort of in-situ
kind of comparisons to advance biology
on life i would guess
right correct no that's correct that's
correct yeah but i don't want to sound
like who was that philosopher
uh 150 years ago who said the stars
they're just lights on the sky
and and we can know you know how right
they are
in the location but we will never know
what they're made of right and and think
about this like we're just here now
imagine a thousand years from now you
know 10
000 years from now we may have a way to
get to this imagine if there's life on
intelligent life on that planet and we
do like a sample return we fly something
by
they send something up we grab it we you
know gravitational slingshot around
their star and we come back
okay so uh so all right i'll just think
a thousand years from now
rather than next week okay
well what you just said those that
answer segway's quite neatly into this
question which i like
and i'm going to combine two different
questions from what tom says who asks
what forms of communication are most
likely to be able to cross between the
stars
and um trumpet wom
who says how do you think we will
overcome the language barrier if we ever
meet another sentient lifeform
i love it and and sarah remember that
movie um
arrival arrival rifle so i got in
trouble
for and i i knew i was gonna get in
trouble for saying this i said
in the movie arrival they brought a
physicist and a linguist
to try to communicate with the alien
when they should have brought an
exobiologist and a cryptographer
and i got so much [ __ ] from the
linguists out there
because this is their one time to appear
in a movie
and there i am just dissing them but
what is your
opinion about how we would actually
communicate i mean i love that movie
i love the concept that it may be so
difficult that we may
we may not find a way to communicate
okay so now she just swept under the rug
neil doesn't like any of my answers but
she's sweeping it i don't know how big
her rug
is
but but how about mathematics how about
symbolism
symbology how about i mean yeah i like
all that assumes
you're okay with them or not i like it i
like it it would have to be something
that is fundamental
in a very mathematical way i agree with
that
because math apparently applies across
the universe so if they discover
something that is
cosmic universal it'll have to be the
cosmic universal things we discovered as
well i presume right
so i wonder so i think one of our
greatest triumphs is the periodic table
of elements
if we can like show that to them and see
if they have a version of it
right because it'd be a lot of
pantomiming initially i would guess
yes before anybody actually uh
communicated
um so it is funny that
you know aliens often just spoke english
you know right right that's why the
arrival is so great
it's such a great movie because it's the
first time they have these beings that
have no way to really
really interact with us right right so
matt give me one more question before we
wrap up this middle segment i will do
and for the people who are watching the
video rather than just the audio i
apologize for the
other life form that keeps walking
across my lap while we're trying to
record
i have no way of communicating with him
uh
well uh so i'm also going to combine
these two questions because they they're
in similar themes
so rob carter asked when searching for
life on other planets is there a
priority of what type of life you look
for
for example would a land-based
land-based life-form take precedence
over an aquatic species
and so forth and then jonathan r brown
asks
carbon-based life on earth developed in
the oceans and diversified exponentially
from there
spreading to land and beyond life on
other worlds may develop from a
different elemental base and begin on
land or in other environments
could et life be too alien for us to
recognize as life and what is the
baseline
and we'll get to that after this break
see what i did there uh so i those are
brilliant
amazing questions that are the
foundations of so much science fiction
storytelling
but uh sarah you have the commercial
break to
figure out what the answer before you
sweep this one under the rug okay
when star talk cosmic queries returns
we're back star talk cosmic queries
search for life
edition uh sarah are you um active on
social media do you have a twitter
account
yes i do it's a prof sarah seeger
p-r-o-f
prof sarah secret and s-e-a-g-e-r right
okay excellent so we can all follow you
there and i assume you talk about
fun stuff like and your research and and
and the like
and facebook as well you can just search
for my name sarah seeger on facebook as
well
okay excellent excellent all right so
matt we left off with a brilliant
pair of questions uh tell me the two
names who asked today
yes that was rob carter and jonathan r
brown and they were both asking about
the types of life forms that you might
find on other planets with
land-based aquatic and so on and whether
we'd even be able to recognize
those things as life or must they be
based on carbon
we won't have a chance to see that life
we'll only see
what life does we'll see the byproducts
of that life
because the telescopes aren't good
enough yet right right we can't we only
see the
we'll only see the planet far away we
won't even see it in some cases it'll be
a pale blue dot
or we'll just see it's we'll just see
its atmosphere as backlit by its star so
we won't see the animals
so the point is when you study the
chemistry of the atmosphere
it's a remarkable feat of of
observational astrophysics
because the light from the star behind
it passes through
the transparent atmosphere and then the
molecules leave their fingerprint and
that's what you're studying
right that's the way we're studying
exoplanet atmospheres today that's right
so we're a long way off from you
watching something wave to you
in the in the telescope we are but you
know funnily enough it doesn't stop
you got an answer yeah i do have an
answer that's good
well i was gonna say it doesn't stop us
from speculating about what life
might be like i want you to just imagine
for a moment because there are
exoplanets are so diverse they're
different masses and sizes and
we're imagining their atmospheres are
all different imagine a planet where the
atmosphere is so massive and heavy
that it's a similar density to water so
imagine you have a water ocean and above
that is a
heavy dense atmosphere you could imagine
things like flying fish
that can just move between the
atmosphere and the water because it's
the same
same density yeah we've all
we love to imagine a planet that is
somewhat dark because of a massive
atmosphere
and we like to imagine this idea of
birds with giant wings
that are photosynthetic that the wings
are like giant plant leaves they can fly
up to where there is sunlight
and gain energy from the sun that way
sarah that reminds me
some science fiction writer forgive me
for not remembering there was a punch
line in it
where the aliens come to the earth they
see what we all do here and then they
return to their home planet
and they report on what they discovered
and they said
they're all made of meat
and and because we basically eat each
other
right life eats other life unless you're
a plant in which case you eat right
so i mean just think about that so if
you
are a bird that has photosynthetic wings
then to eat you like you just said you
just go to a
altitude where you get the sunlight and
then come back down and you're not
killing anything
for yourself then you would presumably
be pray
for whatever is in the lower levels
because they aren't accessing their
sunlight
you'd want to make sure they're
photosynthetic too
but imagine a whole world where that's
the case and they come visit us
and we have all these slaughterhouses
and not just us other animals eat other
animals
and this would look like a really bloody
nasty place to them
very nice would you guys ever think
about that no no but it sounds pretty
scary
okay so tell me also about a
carbon-based life how yeah
what do you think sam couch actually
asked this specifically while we're
doing that he
uh sam asks um is it possible to have
life elsewhere that is not carbon-based
and if so what would that look like
compared to carbon-based life and what
would be the requirements for that life
to survive
yeah there really hasn't been a lot of
solid work done in that area it's
it's really hard to construct you know
a biochemistry of like a completely
different type of life out there
we're not sure if silicon based life is
even really possible
we think silicon you know a lot of our
silicon here on earth for example it's
locked away into rocks and there's just
not a lot of silicon we think silicon
compounds are often they dissolve in
water too easily
so i think the jury is still out on that
one
okay so even though silicon makes the
same families of molecules as carbon
does
because they they're top and bottom to
each other on the periodic tables as we
learned in
high school chemistry that they'll all
make the same kinds of molecules
but you're saying the the other
properties of silicon molecules
make them wholly different from what
carbon is giving us yes
so so so our search for life is
justifiably carbon-based not to put
words in your mouth but that's kind of
what you're saying yeah you said it well
that's right
matt did she sweet no i i think that rug
is fully lifted and
the items underneath are exposed
and all right all right okay this one
this one's pitting
host against guest here josh v asks
dr tyson has spoken in the past star
talk episodes about the idea of
goldilocks zones
being antiquated at best and possibly
the wrong approach to searching for life
what is professor sega's opinion on the
use and definition of goldilocks zones
as it applies to what galactic locations
are prioritized
in searching the vast cosmos wow
actually this is one where
neil and i agree actually so just to go
into some detail
the habitable zone it's a good construct
the goldilocks zone it helps us think of
where we should be looking for planets
but in reality i think it really depends
on the individual planet
like i want you to imagine a planet that
instead of having an atmosphere like
ours that is mostly nitrogen and it has
a good amount of oxygen
imagine a planet that has a hydrogen
atmosphere dominated by hydrogen
did you know hydrogen is a nasty potent
greenhouse gas
way worse than any of the gases we have
on our planet earth
so a planet with hydrogen it turns out
it could still be the right temperature
far outside to what we think of as this
traditional goldilocks zone because it
has such a powerful greenhouse and they
wouldn't call it nasty
they would be thankful for it they would
need it or their planet
yes they would need it right right right
so i like to think of habit
habitability concept as being you know
planet independent not your location in
the galaxy or
your location in your own planetary
system but dependent on the properties
of the planet
so that's an enlightened modern view of
the concept of a zone
so the zone is not a it's a virtual zone
in that sense
because it can take it's it can be in
places that are not just
in the in the narrow-minded swath
that's around the sun so that's good i
hadn't i hadn't thought about these
other kinds of
goldilocks zones you're referencing and
for all we know even the definitions
we've come up with now
20 30 years from now carrie and violetta
the eight-year-old
or the eight and twelve-year-old
listening to this in their day they
might look back at
our definition broadened definition of a
goldilocks don't say
what do they know they because they
at fault there could be like life inside
of volcanoes or something i mean
who knows right right and we haven't
observed any rocky exoplanet atmospheres
yet
we're just beginning so right right
right okay
so what i want to do now is go into a
semi-lightning round
and so sarah pretend you're on the
evening news and the whole interview is
going to last just a couple of minutes
and so so this is your sound bite
quiz can you give us a sample you've
been very good in this
program so far so i think it'll come out
in flying colors
so matt so uh i i i think i know the
answer to this one
but uh andrew guendro asks my question
is about the probability of life in the
universe finding each other
if we think of the universe as infinite
and the axis of time as
infinite does it stand to reason the
probability of life in different areas
of the universe finding each other on
both axes time and space approaches
zero my guess is no but
uh i want to hear from the scientists
sarah
okay i didn't totally get that the last
part of that so he's saying
if everything's infinite life should i
shouldn't find each other i think
i think the question is if we're dealing
with an infinite universe
and a finite amount of life would that
not
be so far apart from each other that it
couldn't find it
each other no he had he added another
dimension it let's say life
is there and we're here and we go there
when we find them
okay if space is infinite
that reduces the likelihood that they're
just going to be
there they're going to be probably much
farther away from us that's the first
axis on this the other axis is maybe the
life is there now but they're not going
to be there in 100 years
so you have to intersect not only in
time
but in place and if both the time axis
and the place axis are infinite
what hope do we have of ever making
contact i think i got his question
i think he's got i think i got that you
got it yes yes
it really all depends on how common life
is if life is rare
then yes that question is an answer is
valid but we all want to believe that we
will we see
but we see the ingredients for life
everywhere and so we have every reason
to hope that on each rocky planet
that's the right temperature that
there's a chance for life there okay and
but but in terms of how how far we've
actually searched
my favorite reference there is an
an analogy given by a jill tarter
of the seti institute and i've i've so
good i've given this 100 times since
then and i
we got her to say it on star talk so we
we have it
wrong i know what you're going to say i
know what you're in our archives
it's you can ask how much of the
universe has researched
before we start saying there's no life
here and if you look at all the
parameter space
time space frequency of bandwidth
right you could be trying to say hi in
one frequency and they're trying to hide
another frequency
and their ships passing in the night and
you both conclude that there is no
sign of intelligent life so she said
it's like
going up to the ocean scooping a cup
an empty cup filling it with ocean water
looking at it and saying
there are no whales in the ocean
so in terms of how much total volume
that of space time frequency is
searchable
and so that was depressing but
fascinating at the same time for me
right right
but at the same time now i'm going to
turn the tables and
do the opposite of trashing all the the
comments
like if you're scooping up that one
glass of water
surely there is some kind of life in
there
and so when we're we're scooping up by
looking at the nearest planets
you know if we look at we're we're
looking at the nearest planets and you
know if there is life there
where wait let me try to say this better
so we're thinking that we can look at
the nearest stars and the nearest
planets
and that the ingredients for life are
everywhere and that they should come
together
often enough that we have a chance of
finding signs of life
excellent excellent so that's like
taking a scoop of anywhere
soil on earth there's going to be life
in it right or any air
air parcel even air very cool very cool
matt let's all right david newman says
is it possible that the galaxies we
observe relatively easily are less
likely to have life than the dwarf
galaxies are wandering stars in deep
space which are more difficult to see
could wandering stars or dwarf galaxies
in deep space be less threatening to
life
well at the moment we're only able to
observe the very nearest stars we can't
see
other galaxies so that question's out of
our
out of our purview at the moment however
each star is fairly isolated
and each star has its own planetary
system as far as we can tell so it
shouldn't matter which galaxy
the planet is in in relation to whether
life is there or not
and we see the same kinds of stars in
most galaxies
are there differences of course but that
repeats enough i i agree with you
we will be perfectly happy searching
stars in our own galaxy
without having to go to others just to
wonder if it's different
but another point implicit there is
there are some galaxies that have very
rocking active nuclei with very deadly
radiation coming out
and it could be that some galaxies are
hostile
to the formation of complex molecules
and more peaceful galaxies like the
dwarf galaxies
that they may be more hospitable i mean
we don't really know this yet
and i agree sarah there's still much
more searching to go
before we start creating a galactic
model for what life would or should be
like
let's get one more question matt see if
we can get it i'm really on a combining
kick today
because these are both quite
philosophical jeff thomas asks we as a
species love to stimulate our senses by
watching movies listening to music
telling stories and more
assuming an alien civilization is
interested in leisure could we
hypothesize what a
stimulation of different senses would
look like outside of our familiar five
and look for evidence of such things and
then chris hampton says what effect do
you think the discovery of alien life
would have on society
would borders eventually dissipate and
self-identification move
from russian american et cetera to
earthling how long would the initial
pandemonium laughs
i think um
in one sound bite i think i was going to
ask neil for that because neil is so
articulate and good at speaking i think
you should take a crack at it
i'll i'll take a quick crack at it it is
interesting when you find something
that's more
other than you are from each from
[Music]
among yourselves it does have a it is
does act as a kind of binding force
and sometimes for the good sometimes not
but i had hoped
that we would have had this kind of
binding force in the face
of battling kovid kovid was like an
alien
then it doesn't care what your skin
color is or your gender or gender
expression
or who you have sex with or any it
doesn't care it'll infect you
and and that would be a good place to
band together and fight
and we failed that test so
i i i wish i had more confidence than i
currently do
and how we would react collectively as a
species
to uh an alien be they friendly or
hostile
and the others about what kind of
version of stories and art and music and
would alien civilization have different
from ours or how would we interact with
it
sarah do you guys think much about the
senses that a
alien might have no
i mean is that is that something that
you could look for and look for evidence
of or ways that they could have changed
their environment to accommodate
the different ways that they that they
interact with each other
the way we do no i mean if you think
about it for a moment
our oxygen on earth life on earth
bacteria cyanobacteria
you know billions of years ago they
re-engineered our atmosphere
they completely changed our atmosphere
so it was unrecognizable
so we can see giant things like that but
small things like
that animals do or that aliens would do
those are out of our
a possibility for now yeah but you're
being
like straight scientists there but now
let me ask you sarah seeger the human
being
who watches science fiction movies
can you imagine well if if an alien had
another sense
what might it be yeah that's a tough one
i don't have a good answer for that i
don't i can take any answer
it doesn't have to be good well
sometimes i i do like to think about our
own planet earth and
all the intelligent life here you know
like the dolphins
and octopus and there's a lot of
creatures here that we
we think are highly intelligent and so i
do like to think about how they interact
with each other and what signs they give
each other
my favorite new yorker comic we got to
end and was
there were two dolphins swimming
together and they're looking up
at two humans talking to each other
looking out of the water and they see
them and one dolphin says to the other
they face each other and make sounds but
it's not clear that they're actually
communicating
dolphin with brains bigger than ours uh
sarah it was been a delight to have you
on
um and we neglected to even mention that
you were co-author on
the recent discovery of um
[Music]
of phosphine a molecule on in the upper
atmosphere of venus
a possible product of life i know that
that
result is still getting contested but
it's fun to watch science
at its best when ideas come forth and
people try to explain it
in multiple ways so just good luck on
that it was great to see you
yeah active in that and and in your in
your
part memoir the smallest lights in the
universe it's
it's a delight to see that
contains a first-hand account not only
of your life but the birth of an entire
cottage industry
in our beloved field of astrophysics uh
the search for exoplanets in the search
for life itself
so great to have you on thank you thanks
for having me all right and matt always
good to have you man oh it's a pleasure
thanks for having me
and we'll look for you on probably
science yes please thank you i got it
in one right and also your book as well
now we've got to give that another plug
oh sorry
another another plug for cosmic queries
if you like this format
um and if you're listening you probably
do because it's one of our most popular
uh we just put it all in one book it's
got the deepest questions like what is
life and what is the universe made of
and how
how did it begin how will it end and are
there multiverses and
so we're very proud of that book as a
start talk community
because it's a lot of it has been
inspired by
shows like this where you write in and
ask your deepest questions
and that inspired us to put the book out
there and it's a product of the star
trek
family i'm neil degrasse tyson your
personal astrophysicist
as always